throw to half back here on the rich
eisen show is uh the star
uh of the kaminsky method which can be
seen for streaming
in its third season on netflix coming up
this very friday
he is michael douglas on the rich eisen
show how are you michael
good rich very very very well proudly
more a little flexibility you know i
think everybody's just happy to
spread their wings a little bit spread
their wings a little bit
absolutely i totally agree with you but
hey there's still enough time to sit
inside and watch the kaminsky method so
we got it
yeah you can do it by yourself you don't
you know you don't have to have empty
bleachers
that's true you just do it all by
yourself exactly right
uh i don't know if you caught anything
as you were uh going on
about your business coming uh up for
this big uh
uh release week of of the show but
uh madison square garden was hopping for
for the knicks this past
week um do you have any good memories of
going to madison square garden seeing
any games
from i i i i sure do i mean the next
knicks from my team um years years ago
uh and between you know bill bradley
dave the bush
earl the pearl every night this was just
it was just spectacular
so it makes me really happy to see this
pleasant
uh turn around on this season i think
was unexpected
thanks for hoping but maybe they got the
right coach and everything seems to be
moving well so it's it's exciting
i'm a heat fan and uh you know
um pat riley and i've had old buddies
for for for years and years that have
followed him
and uh i'm sure they're getting warmed
up for
when milwaukee comes to miami to figure
out what the hell to do
yeah that's an interesting um you know
so
the relationship with you and pat riley
um
does does that stem from wall street
because a lot of people thought
that you looked like pat riley and
gordon gekko had
the riles lid and everything
else about him i i actually it did
because one of the last character
decisions that i made
about gordon gekko was when i was down
visiting pat in miami in one night and
pat
loves cars loves hot rods like i love
hot rods
and he has a couple of beautiful 47
mercs beautiful convertible
47 mercs and i was uh one night we were
in miami and i was sitting in the back
seat and
pat was in the front seat with his wife
chris and
the top was down i was watching pat i
said
damn his hair isn't even moving his hair
just like the top is down and everything
else and i said this is a really
i said for gekko gordon gekko so i did i
stole my hairdo from pat no
kidding does he is he aware of that oh
yes he is he
he's happy to tell you right after he
introduced himself pat riley miami he
the ring he goes yeah he recognized
gordon gekko
that wow that is phenomenal so um so you
go back with pat riley and thus a miami
heat fan
right now uh is it true your your
football team is the jets though
michael are you yes it is yes it is i i
don't have a paper bag over my head
but you know i just why the why the jets
where did where did that come from where
is that uh
joe namath man joe namath i was a i was
a giants fan
i was a giants fan and then was it was
it
uh super bowl three when he made the big
prediction
and they won and i said ah between this
guy and he wasn't afraid to wear the fur
coats of the white shoes and he had the
girls
and you never you know he didn't hear
about training and he just seemed to be
enjoying himself so much so uh i
i became that's a long time to be hoping
for something else to happen
super bowl free it's been a long time
for the uh
for the football gods i've just been
kicking jets fans in uh
in in the nether regions for for half a
century but namath is one of my favorite
people
i've ever met on the planet he's another
now uh south florida guy have you ever
crossed paths with joe namathy or days
michael douglas i have
i mean i have it you know at uh jets
games and stuff over
over the seasons always handles himself
a very well charming guy and uh it looks
good he's got to be what
84 85 he's he's
he's just um he's i think he's ageless i
don't know what age is i think he's he's
one of those guys that just never ages
god bless him yes sir we you like about
on the kaminsky method
so it's it's always
i know um and i would love to i'd love
to get to that in
here on the rich eisen show i've got
michael douglas um what have you learned
about i guess life or yourself or
anything
um of that i guess
nature through your work on the show
and what uh and what your character's
gone through through the first two
seasons
and now this third one michael
well uh i like my job i'm i'm really
happy after 50 years
in the biz to say how much i still
really enjoy acting
and for me the kaminsky method was
amongst other things it was an
opportunity and a chance to try out my
my comedic chops which is something i'm
not necessarily known for
knows something that i've done very
often but you know under this
great writing of chuck laurie and and
the wonderful cast we put together
it was a chance i found understanding
about comedy by comic
timing comic delivery comedy is
is much more difficult to do than drama
i think that's why we
we all tend to cherish our friends that
are funny
because uh we don't have as many funny
friends as we've got serious friends
so it's a it's a great ability and so
these these
this third season now and really was
originally a two-season commitment with
alan arkin
and then i was having such a good time
in this sort of ensemble format
working with this wonderful cast and
these great scripts i really wanted to
do another season
uh alan i think it had it you know he's
10 years older than i am and so it's
hard work but chuck and then we all
decided to put on another season
together i'm really happy about it it's
coming out on friday
uh may 28th and um
i guess what the reminder for me is i
really haven't done a this is a
streaming show but it's just close to
like a television series
that is a half hour show now there's no
commercials
so you can the half hour show can be 25
minutes long it can be 40 minutes long
it really doesn't matter and it's
fabulous
in the sense that we also in the
kaminsky method we go
directly in real time from one episode
to the next
so yeah when you do only six or eight
episodes streaming becomes a really
big part of this and people seem to
inhale uh
the series in in in one one swoop
it's a good way to put it it's a good
way to put it just to inhale and take it
all in and obviously that's the benefit
of being on
a streamer like netflix so um and
and for fans you know who might hear
that well you
you know you don't do comedy that often
it's pretty cool to see you with
kathleen turner back on the screen
as well from the romancing the stone
days and
uh what how how did that come about
was that part of the reason of casting
her in the role
i i i think so when when uh
chuck laurie our our our producer and
also wonderful writer
uh first was talking about this
character he was gonna bring in which
was an
ex-wife um two people who hated each
other
and all i could think about was the war
of the roses
and in kathleen and i said well this is
just
this is great there's like a
continuation exactly in time 30 years
later
or something from that marriage with
with kathleen
so and and it's just a joy one of one of
the
benefits richard when you've worked with
somebody before if you know each other's
rhythms you know
and so we we've seen each other over the
over the years
a bit check in and all of that they
haven't had a chance to work together
and you just picked up like that you
just it's that comfort factor of knowing
each other
you can step on each other's lines you
don't have to go through that formal
introductory period of meeting each
other and and
you just you're just comfortable so it
was a great great plus and she she nails
it she just
kills the catholic does a great job so
what what um
what film did you see your tv show
during the pandemic
that you're flipping around and then you
saw yourself on the screen
it's something maybe you hadn't seen in
a while and you're like wow
that's right i did that right or you
just is it
there's a few of those man let me tell
you i'm just so happy i could actually
see it
it helps you remember where we are i
guess the ghost in the darkness which
which is a picture i haven't seen in a
while it's the film we shot down in
south africa
where i've made a great white hunter um
which was
and it was a difficult shoot but but a
very pleasant being in in south africa
and enjoyed that a lot
okay so that's a creep up on you now you
know
i got 50 years in there and so probably
about 60 60 plus films and then a couple
of the series so they
you know they creep up on you okay and
then what's the one that you get a
residuals check from
every now and then you're like what's
the first one what's the what's your
first visit
you're the first residual check my first
residual
check was probably
my first two or three movies i didn't
get any residuals you know that's right
it wasn't because it wasn't the contract
it was just that there were such turkeys
that uh we didn't go but i'd say
romancing was uh
romancing the stone was probably a first
big
wow look at this show business i love it
yeah i got it yeah i have my residual
check from my csi miami appearance right
here it's four dollars and
94 cents um
i i cashed this baby there's no question
about that sure but
but the frames that it cost three times
that that's right yeah i've got it's
definitely there's no doubt it's
definitely a framer
um what's your favorite sports movie
michael you got one of them
like where are you uh well let's let me
think for a second
yeah i gotta i mean i like what you call
it i love chariots of fire
uh which which was uh was certainly good
whose ears
uh was a lot of fun too i must say i
love that
and then uh which film of yours would
you love to revisit and
do your character again or know where
they are right now
where which one would you be curious to
revisit
and know which michael douglas character
is characters
what they're uh they're doing again i
got a couple
it was uh one picture called black rain
where i played a
new york cop in japan which would love
to know what the hell happened to him
um i also there's a picture i did called
the call called wonder boys
where i played a literary professor down
at carnegie mellon
and uh hopefully he's still alive too
this is two that come to mind
well i'm not a big i i love the process
rich of making movies you know
i don't see them i mean i'll see one
time either at the pre at the
premiere or preview and then as you say
maybe catch it on
on television once in a while but i'm
not a big uh
film buff i mean i i i love movies i
always check out the about awards season
but unfortunately i'm a sports
and news junk okay waste an infinite
number of hours
watching pretty much any sport in most
news
okay well then that's great um so do you
have a prediction for the jets in
2021 michael douglas uh
yeah they're gonna they're gonna win
more games than they did last season
there we go
that's you're really going out on a very
very thick limit
but you know what that's a you know you
could do this for a living
sort of with that like that right it
could go wrong
yeah we could swap roles you know i
could do that no problem
yeah i i said i i got we still got room
in in
on the kaminsky method i don't know you
could give the other scene paul reiser
on the team you could give paul a good
run for his money
okay i'll i'll take him out but at the
meantime i'll just
uh enjoy watching him uh coming up on
friday with
the latest season michael thanks for the
time i always appreciate
you giving me some time big fan of your
work
especially this show and let's do this
again after the jets win the super bowl
this year
i love it have a great week michael
douglas here on the rich eisen show
check out the kaminsky method
coming back on netflix this friday
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here